From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
[PHONE DIALING]
[电话拨号声]
Hello.
你好。
Hi, this is Yousef Hammash?
喂，请问是优素福·哈马什吗？
Yes, it is, loud and clear.
是的，我是，听得很清楚。
Good. Is this still a OK time for you to talk?
太好了。现在方便和你谈谈吗？
Yes.
是的。
OK.
好的。
Yeah, but it's a bit crazy outside, a lot of crowdness. There is a lot of traffic, especially from the children. Let me find a quiet place.
嗯，不过外面有点乱，人很多。交通非常拥堵，尤其是孩子们。让我找个安静的地方。
OK.
好的。
Close the door. Yes.
关上门。好的。
For months, one of our producers, Chana Joffe-Walt, has been talking to Yousef Hammash. He's in Gaza. Back in December, we put out an extra podcast episode, a bonus mini episode with some of those conversations.
几个月来，我们的制作人查娜·乔夫-沃尔特一直在和优素福·哈马什交流。他身处加沙。去年十二月，我们发布了一期额外的播客，一期包含这些对话的迷你特辑。
But so much has happened since then. We wanted to come back to Yousef and do a full episode. And that is what we have for you today. It is a series of unusually frank conversations about what he and his family were experiencing, sometimes as they were experiencing it, and about the decisions they made with the choices they had.
但从那时起发生了太多事。我们想再次联系优素福，制作一期完整的节目。这就是我们今天为你准备的内容。这是一系列极其坦诚的谈话，讲述了他和他的家人所经历的一切，有时是在事件发生的过程中，以及他们如何在有限的选择中做出决定。
So what we're going to do is we're going to play you a lot of stuff from December and then what has happened since then. Yousef is in his early 30s, got two kids and a big extended family. He works for a humanitarian organization operating in Gaza, the Norwegian Refugee Council, the NRC.
所以，我们接下来会为你播放十二月的一些谈话内容，以及在那之后发生的事情。优素福刚过三十岁，有两个孩子，还有一个庞大的大家庭。他在加沙的一家国际人道主义组织——挪威难民理事会（NRC）工作。
And Chana started talking to Yousef in early December, really knowing very little about him or his situation at the beginning. And as you'll hear, more and more unfolds and gets revealed. At that point, he had just relocated with his wife and kids to Rafah, where the NRC office is. Rafah is in the south of Gaza. It's at the border with Egypt. His family was living in the NRC office there.
查娜在十二月初开始与优素福交流，起初对他的个人情况了解甚少。正如你接下来听到的，随着对话深入，更多情况逐渐显露出来。那时，他刚刚带着妻子和孩子搬到了拉法，NRC办公室所在的城市。拉法位于加沙南部，与埃及接壤。他的家人当时就住在那里办公室内。
And so Yousef was in the unusual situation in Gaza where he often did have internet access with solar panels providing power. Meanwhile, the rest of his extended family, including four sisters, was about eight miles away in a town called Khan Yunis. Here's Chana.
因此，优素福处于加沙的一个特殊境地，因为他有太阳能板供电，通常还能上网。与此同时，他的大家庭，包括四个姐妹，当时就在八英里外一个叫汗尤尼斯的城镇。下面请听查娜的报道。
So, talk to me about what did you do today.
那么，跟我说说你今天都做了些什么。
Today, I had to find a place for my extended family, which, humdullah, I found it today. I found a place, and I built a tent-- two tents, actually, because I couldn't find a house to rent or anything. So, tomorrow, I will move the rest of my family here to Rafah from Khan Yunis to these two tents. And today, it takes me a while building these tents.
今天我得为我的大家庭找个住处，感谢真主，我找到了。我找到了一个地方，盖了帐篷——准确说是两个，因为我租不到房子或其他任何地方。所以明天，我会把剩下的家人从汗尤尼斯搬到拉法的这两个帐篷里。今天搭这些帐篷花了我不少时间。
Is there anybody in the family that is hesitant? Do you have to--
家里有人犹豫不决吗？你不得不……
Yes, we have had-- I had-- yes, yes, yeah, yeah, they are part of the family. Yeah, even a few minutes ago, I was having this debate with my sister that was like, OK, I'm pregnant. Because she's pregnant, and she don't want to do the delivery in a tent. And she said like, OK, they are still far, like 1 kilometer away, the tanks. She said that we cannot suffer more. At least we have here bathroom.
是的，我们有过……我有过……是的，没错，他们是家人的一部分。即使是几分钟前，我还和我的一个妹妹争论，她说：“我怀孕了。”因为她怀孕了，不想在帐篷里分娩。她说：“坦克离我们只有一公里远了。我们不能再受苦了。至少这里有厕所。”
The main debate was a bathroom, about having your privacy to use a bathroom. Because when you are fleeing in a tent, there is no bathrooms or that privacy. Well, I'm trying. Tomorrow, I'll find a way to build a bathroom for them.
主要的争议点就是厕所，关于是否有私人空间去上厕所。因为当你逃难住在帐篷里时，是没有厕所或那种隐私的。嗯，我在努力。明天，我会想办法为他们建一个厕所。
Yousef has been moving and convincing his sisters to move since the war began. They all started the war in Jabalia, in the northern part of Gaza. After October 7, when Hamas attacked southern Israel and killed around 1,200 people, took about 240 people hostage, Yousef immediately moved his family from Jabalia to his parents' house in a nearby city, Beit Lahiya. They moved the very next day, October 8.
自战争爆发以来，优素福一直在奔波并劝说他的姐妹们搬迁。他们最初都住在加沙北部的杰巴利耶。10月7日，哈马斯袭击了以色列南部，杀害了约1200人，并劫持了约240名人质。优素福立即将家人从杰巴利耶转移到附近城市拜特拉希耶的父母家中。他们第二天，即10月8日就搬走了。
On October 9, Israeli airstrikes hit Jabalia, and then again on October 12, 19, 22, 31, November 1, 2, 4, and on. Yousef and his family and his sisters' families then fled south to Khan Yunis. They stayed with relatives until Yousef read a leaflet that fell from the sky. It said, you must evacuate immediately and go to shelters in the city of Rafah. The city of Khan Yunis is a dangerous combat zone. Forewarned is forearmed. It was signed the Israeli Defense Forces.
10月9日，以色列空袭了杰巴利耶，随后又在10月12、19、22、31日，以及11月1、2、4日等日子持续轰炸。优素福和他的家人以及他姐妹们的家庭随后逃往南部的汗尤尼斯。他们一直和亲戚待在一起，直到优素福读到了一张从天而降的传单。传单上写着：“立即撤离并前往拉法市的避难所。汗尤尼斯市是危险的战区。未雨绸缪。”落款是以色列国防军。
That's when he fled to Rafah with his wife and his kids. By that point in the war, over 15,000 people in Gaza had been killed. The place Yousef works, the NRC, had rented an office in Rafah, in the area the Israelis were now saying was a safe zone. Yousef moved his immediate family into the office, but his sisters and their families weren't so sure they wanted to follow this time. So Yousef, from the moment he got to Rafah, had been pushing his sisters in Khan Yunis to come. He'd been at that for almost a week.
就在那时，他带着妻子和孩子逃到了拉法。战争进行到那个阶段，加沙已有超过15000人丧生。优素福工作的机构NRC在拉法租了一间办公室，那个地区当时被以色列人称为“安全区”。优素福将核心家庭搬进了办公室，但他的姐妹们及其家庭这次却不太确定是否要跟随。所以，从到达拉法的那一刻起，优素福就一直在劝说他在汗尤尼斯的姐妹们过来。他已经在那儿忙活了快一周了。
To be honest, each one of them have its own personality, and I have to persuade her the way I know. Each one of them. One of them, she's worried about her father-in-law and mother-in-law and was like, OK, they are not safe, and they are on the street. I'll build them a tent. But I want to make sure that you are with me here. I'll bring them also.
老实说，她们每个人都有自己的个性，我必须用我知道的方式去劝说她们。每个人都是。其中一个担心她的公公婆婆，说：“他们不安全，流落在街上。”我说：“我会给他们搭个帐篷。但我一定要确保你和我在一起。我也会把他们接过来。”
The other one, I had to do the same option with her. OK, I'll bring your father-in-law and their entire family. I'll take care of them. But I want you to come here.
另一个，我也用了同样的方案。好了，我会把你公公婆婆和他们全家都接过来。我会照顾他们。但我希望你过来。
What about the woman who's pregnant?
那个怀孕的姐妹呢？
I keep doing-- yeah, the one who is pregnant, she's the youngest. And she's the most stubborn one. Yeah, she's the youngest. When we came to the south, there was no military operation on the ground. She refused, and her father-in-law and mother-in-law refused. I had a fight with them. And I told them, listen, I want my sister with me. And we had a bit of argue because they didn't expect what's coming.
我一直在做……是的，那个怀孕的是最小的妹妹。她是最固执的一个。是的，她是最小的。我们刚到南部时，地面还没有军事行动。她拒绝了，她的公公婆婆也拒绝了。我和他们吵了一架。我告诉他们：“听着，我想要我的姐妹和我在一起。”我们争论了一番，因为他们没预料到未来会发生什么。
Yeah, I hadn't thought about how each time, you have to mentally convince yourself that the place that you're in, which is feeling OK at that moment, might not feel OK very soon.
是的，我之前没考虑到，你每一次都得在心理上说服自己，你现在觉得还算安全的地方，可能很快就不安全了。
Yeah, because, yeah, and who would ever imagine that the Israeli tanks will be in the center of Jabalia camp? Or who would ever imagine that they would be in Shifa Hospital? These things, we never imagined that it will be a real thing that we are seeing by our own eyes. We never thought about that.
是啊，因为，谁能想到以色列坦克会开进杰巴利耶难民营的中心？或者谁能想到他们会进驻希法医院？这些事情，我们从未想过会亲眼看到，变成现实。我们从未那样想过。
Yousef was lobbying his sisters to move as hard as he could. But honestly, he himself wasn't always totally sure about bringing them to Rafah. Yousef kept searching for new information about what the Israeli military was planning to do next. He'd ask everyone he met, looked everywhere online, except a few places he avoided.
优素福竭尽全力游说他的姐妹们搬迁。但说实话，他自己有时也不完全确定把她们带到拉法是否正确。优素福一直在寻找关于以色列军方下一步计划的新信息。他问遍了遇到的每一个人，在网上到处搜索，除了几个他回避的地方。
I don't open my Facebook, for example, or Instagram because all my friends from Gaza are there. Because I don't want to know who's dead. I don't want to know. And I don't have the time to respect these people who I lose. By coincidence, a few days ago, I found out that my uncle is dead. I didn't know about that before. And a friend of mine told me that. Oh, yaniya. We were just having a chat, and I mentioned him. And he didn't know that he was my uncle. And I was talking like that, oh, he's my uncle. And he's like, oh, yeah, I'm sorry for your loss. I was like, what?
比如我不会打开我的脸书或Instagram，因为我所有来自加沙的朋友都在那儿。我不想知道谁死了。我不想知道。我没有时间去哀悼那些我失去的人。巧合的是，几天前，我发现我的叔叔死了。我之前根本不知道。是一个朋友告诉我的。哦，天哪。我们当时只是在聊天，我提到了他。对方不知道那是我叔叔，我就那样说：“哦，他是我叔叔。”对方说：“噢，对不起，节哀顺变。”我当时就懵了：“什么？”
Aw.
天呐。
I didn't know. It was like two weeks ago. He's dead. He's killed two weeks ago in Jabalia while I didn't know.
我不知道。那是两周前的事了。他死了。他两周前在杰巴利耶被杀害了，而我当时竟一无所知。
How did that come up in that conversation?
这在对话中是怎么提起来的？
We were mentioning where his parents living in Jabalia, and I was like, OK, my relatives living there. They are from Ajouri family. And he was like, yeah, yeah, I know them. I was like, yeah, he's my uncle. He's like, yeah, sorry for your loss. And I was like, no, no, no, he's alive. He's not. He was killed in an airstrike. I know, I know. And I felt a bit stupid. And it was really weird feeling that I didn't know that my uncle is dead since two weeks. He was killed.
我们当时在提到他的父母住在杰巴利耶，我说：“好的，我的亲戚住在那儿。他们是Ajouri家族的。”对方说：“啊，我知道他们。”我说：“是的，他是我叔叔。”对方说：“是的，节哀顺变。”我说：“不，不，不，他还活着。他没死。”（他其实是在空袭中丧生的。）我知道，我知道。我当时感觉自己像个傻瓜。那种感觉真的很奇怪，我竟然两周了都不知道叔叔已经去世了。他是被杀害的。
Do you--
你……
The other thing-- OK, just to continue on this story--
另一件事——好了，继续讲这个故事——
Please.
请讲。
Yesterday, my brother who lives in Sweden, my cousin, who is the son of my uncle I mentioned, he was asking my brother to check if I have information about his father. And I don't want to be that-- also to deliver the news for him that his father was killed.
昨天，我住在瑞典的兄弟，也就是我提到的那位叔叔的儿子，问我能不能帮忙打听他父亲的消息。我不想成为那个……传递他父亲被杀噩耗的人。
Have you told him?
你告诉他了吗？
No, I told him there is no connection between the south and the north. And it's impossible to reach anyone there, which is true 'cause there is no phone call. There is nothing that-- you cannot reach anyone in the north. And I was like, I will try to check what's the situation, but I didn't want to be the one who's giving the news.
没有，我告诉他南部和北部之间没有任何联系。无法联系到那边的任何人，这是真的，因为没电话，什么都没有……你根本联系不上北方。我说：“我会试着查查情况。”但我不想成为那个发布噩耗的人。
Oh, Yousef. So you just couldn't bring yourself to tell him what you had heard?
噢，优素福。所以你只是无法让自己说出你听到的真相？
Yes. Even my mother, who is with me now, doesn't know.
是的。甚至我现在身边的母亲，也不知道。
Is it her brother?
那是她兄弟吗？
Yes.
是的。
And you're not going to tell her?
你打算不告诉她吗？
Definitely not. And I'm saying that here because I'm sure that they don't understand English, first of all. And second thing, they won't listen-- sorry for that. But they're in Gaza. They won't listen to this podcast to know from this podcast that-- yeah.
绝对不告诉。我在这里说出来是因为我确定他们听不懂英语，首先。第二，他们不会听——抱歉——他们身处加沙。他们不会听到这个播客，从而从播客里知道这件事。是的。
Ah. I always don't-- ya'ani. It's one of the first times that I really speak about these things, and it seems weird for me that I always, in front of everyone around me, I'm the man who's managing everything and supporting anyone in need. And if you need anything, the best one to call is Yousef, you know. Now, I'm helpless, useless. And I cannot do anything. I cannot even manage my own need.
啊。我一直不……天哪。这是我第一次真正谈论这些事情，对我来说似乎很奇怪，因为在所有人面前，我一直是那个负责打理一切、支持所有有需要的人的男人。如果你需要任何东西，最好的求助对象就是优素福，你知道。现在，我无助、没用。我什么都做不了。我甚至连自己的需求都照顾不了。
So, if your uncle comes up, your mom mentions him or your wife says, oh, I wonder how he's doing, you will not say anything?
所以，如果提到你叔叔，或者你母亲提到他，又或者你妻子说“不知道他现在怎么样了”，你什么都不会说吗？
It happens, and I didn't say anything. Yes, it happened yesterday, and I was like, no, I am not going to say anything. My brain was like circling around, and I was like, OK, you have to tell her. She deserves to know that her brother is dead. And I was like, no. It's her right to know, and she will blame me a lot when she knows that I was knowing without telling her. I have to shut down my brain. It's like, no, you turn off. It's not your role now.
这种事发生过，我什么也没说。是的，昨天刚发生过，我心想：“不，我什么都不会说的。”我的大脑在不停地纠结，我心想：“你得告诉她。她有权知道她兄弟已经死了。”而我的理智告诉我：“不。那是她的知情权，但她知道我一直瞒着她，肯定会狠狠地责怪我。”我必须关掉我的大脑。就像是：“不，你关机吧。这不是你现在该扮演的角色。”
Not your what?
不是你的什么？
It's not your role.
这不是我的角色。
Not your role.
不是你的角色。
You don't need to be functioning now.
你现在不需要正常运转。
Mm-hmm, yeah. Focus on building tents.
嗯，是的。专注于搭帐篷吧。
I have-- to be honest, I have plenty of to-do list. On my list, there's many things. My priority now, it's the time to secure my family and manage their needs more than anything else. For me, looking for their safety, it's not about them only. It's more about me. I cannot imagine for a moment losing one of them, one of my sisters. It has to be me before them.
老实说，我有很多待办事项。清单上有很多事情。我现在最优先的任务是保护好家人，管理好他们的需求，这比什么都重要。对我来说，寻找他们的安全，不仅仅是为了他们。更是为了我自己。我无法想象失去其中任何一个姐妹。那一定是在我死之前。
Because I don't have the strength to even to think about losing one of them. That's why I'm doing it, not because of you-- it's because of me. I don't have that. I am weak to have the strength to handle losing any one of them. I don't have that strength.
因为我没有那种力量去想失去她们中任何一个的后果。这就是我为什么这么做，不是为了别人，而是为了我。我没有。我太脆弱了，没有力量去承受失去她们任何一人的后果。我没有那种力量。
Do you think they do it for you?
你觉得她们是为了你才做的吗？
Ya'ani, they came to Khan Yunis with me for me. No one agreed. It was really hard, and I had to fight with my mother. And it was like-- but they came because I want them. I want them to be with me.
天哪，她们跟我一起来到汗尤尼斯是为了我。没人同意。那真的很难，我不得不和我母亲吵架。但她们来了，因为我需要她们。我希望她们和我在一起。
So they do it for you.
所以她们是为了你。
That time, yes, it was for me.
那一次，是的，是为了我。
And this time?
这次呢？
This time, I think I will prepare everything. I will prepare the tents. I'll find you a place. Then I'll move you once when everything's ready to have you. And what pushed me to finish everything today is that Benjamin Netanyahu, he was threatening Hezbollah. He was like saying, Hezbollah, you should stop what you are doing because if start a war, we will turn Beirut into Gaza and Khan Yunis. So I was like, OK, now it's Khan Yunis. I need to grab them from there. They are in the center of Khan Yunis.
这次，我想我会准备好一切。我会准备好帐篷。我会给你们找个住处。然后等一切准备就绪，我就把你们接过来。今天让我下定决心完成这一切的原因是，本杰明·内塔尼亚胡在威胁黎巴嫩真主党。他当时说：“真主党，你们应该停止现在的行动，因为如果开战，我们会把贝鲁特变成加沙和汗尤尼斯。”所以我心想：“好吧，现在轮到汗尤尼斯了。我得赶紧把她们从那儿接出来。”她们就在汗尤尼斯的中心地带。
Did you send them that quote?
你把那段话发给她们了吗？
Yep. [LAUGHS] Because a lot of people stay until the last moment. And when they evacuate, they will evacuate under bombing. And I don't want my sisters to experience that.
是的。[笑] 因为很多人会一直待到最后一刻。当他们撤离时，他们会在轰炸下逃生。我不希望我的姐妹们经历那种事。
What does the tent look like?
帐篷是什么样子的？
Ah, so there is two types of tents. Now I became expert, by the way.
啊，帐篷有两种。我现在成专家了，顺便说一下。
I was going to ask you how you know to build tents so quickly.
我正想问你是怎么知道如何快速搭建帐篷的。
So one I get it through NRC, where I work. And it was with instruction. That was easy. The other one is like wooden sticks with plastic. The hardest part was finding a suitable place to rent a small land, not randomly in the streets. It's a agricultural area. It's a bit sandy everywhere.
一种是我通过NRC得到的，我在那工作。有说明书。那个很简单。另一种是木棍加塑料布。最难的部分是找到合适的地方租一小块地，不能随便在街上搭。那是农业区。到处都是沙子。
So you rent a land. You didn't just--
所以你租了地。你不只是……
A lot of airstikes. Wow.
好多空袭。哇。
I'm sorry, what?
抱歉，你说什么？
No, it was massive airstrike. [LAUGHS]
不，是巨大的空袭。[笑]
Just now?
就在刚才？
Yeah. Yes. Another airstrike. They're getting crazy somehow, all of this in Khan Yunis.
是的。是的。又一次空袭。他们疯了，汗尤尼斯现在到处都是。
The explosions are in Khan Yunis right now?
现在爆炸是在汗尤尼斯吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Another one.
是的，是的，是的。又来了一次。
OK.
好的。
What's going on? I'll call you in a minute, OK?
怎么回事？我一会儿打给你，好吗？
No problem. No problem.
没问题。没问题。
I just need to check, OK?
我只是需要去确认一下，好吗？
No problem.
没问题。
Just one minute, and I'll call you back.
就一分钟，我回给你。
Take your time. Bye.
不急。再见。
Because it seems really massive there. OK.
因为那边的爆炸似乎非常剧烈。好的。
OK, bye. Hi.
好的，再见。你好。
Hello?
你好？
Hi.
你好。
Yes, sorry.
是的，抱歉。
Is everybody OK?
大家都还好吗？
Just want to make sure that they're still alive. Yeah, they're alive.
只是想确保她们还活着。是的，她们还活着。
Do you literally write, are you alive?
你真的是发信息问：“你们还活着吗？”吗？
Yeah, it was a funny message from my sister. Are you alive?
是的，那是我姐妹发来的搞笑信息。你们还活着吗？
Wait, that's funny?
等等，这很搞笑？
Yeah, because I had to send emojis laughing. That's how we are talking always, even when I'm with them. It's like, OK, we have one more day to live. Let's enjoy it. Maybe two days. OK.
是的，因为我不得不发笑的表情。我们总是这么说话，即使我和她们在一起时也一样。就像是：“好吧，我们又多活了一天。享受它吧。也许还能再活两天。好的。”
So you wrote her, are you alive, smiley face?
所以你给她发了“你们还活着吗，笑脸”？
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, my God. Yeah, and she writes back yes, or she laughs?
天哪。是的，然后她回复“是的”，或者她发笑？
Yeah, she laughs. And she said it's a bit calm. A bit calm. OK, I don't know what this means, a bit calm, but ya'ani.
是的，她笑了。她说现在稍微平静一点。稍微平静一点。好的，我不知道这意味着什么，稍微平静一点，但，天哪。
I'll let you go. I've taken so much of your time.
我不耽误你了。我占用了你太多时间。
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
And tomorrow, what's going to happen is your sisters are going to move?
明天，会发生什么，你姐妹们要搬家了吗？
Yeah, this is going to be the early thing for me to do in the morning because I don't want them to move under the bombing. So I want to evacuate them when it's a bit calm and manageable without risks. So I'll do it in the early morning. But maybe because of this rain-- ahh, I need to assess the situation tomorrow morning. I promise them that we will make decision together this time tomorrow morning.
是的，这将是我明早要做的第一件事，因为我不希望她们在轰炸中搬迁。所以我希望在稍微平静且风险可控的情况下撤离她们。所以我会一大早就去做。但也许因为这场雨……啊，我明天早上需要评估一下情况。我向她们承诺过，我们明天早上会一起做决定。
But you've already made the decision that you want them to go.
但你已经做出了希望她们离开的决定。
Yes. Yes.
是的。是的。
OK. I hope you have an easy night, and I will check in with you tomorrow.
好的。希望你有个安稳的夜晚，我明天再联系你。
That's a good phrase-- easy night. [LAUGHS] OK, inshallah. Thank you. Thank you.
这个词不错——安稳的夜晚。[笑] 好的，因沙阿拉（真主保佑）。谢谢。谢谢。
OK, bye.
好的，再见。
Thank you. Bye-bye.
谢谢。再见。
Hi, Yousef?
你好，优素福？
Hello?
你好？
Did your sisters move today?
你姐妹们今天搬家了吗？
Unfortunately, not yet. They were refusing to leave without a bathroom, but today, there were a lot of tanks and airstrikes. No, I promised them that tomorrow it's going to be-- there will be a bathroom tomorrow. And I'll make my best to make it happen.
很不幸，还没。她们拒绝在没有厕所的情况下离开，但今天，坦克和空袭很多。不，我向她们保证明天一定会……明天会有厕所的。我会尽我所能让它实现。
I want to jump in and say a little bit about what Yousef doing his best looks like, an incomplete summary of that particular day. He spent the morning trying to track down trucks for the Norwegian Refugee Council, where he works. The trucks were full of aid, things like bedding, tents, buckets for water, that should have arrived at the border, but he couldn't check online if they were there because the system was down, and the phones weren't working. So he went in person, wandered around, looking at plate numbers. Could not find the trucks.
我想插一句，描述一下优素福“尽我所能”是什么样子，这是那一天的简要概括。他花了整个上午试图为工作的挪威难民理事会寻找卡车。卡车装满了救援物资，比如寝具、帐篷、水桶，本应到达边境，但他无法在线检查它们是否到达，因为系统崩溃了，电话也不通。所以他亲自去寻找，四处游荡，查看车牌号。没能找到卡车。
Then he went to the market to find medicine for his wife, Manal, who's sick. Could not find medicine. In the midst of all this, he got a call from another relative who was fleeing and needed a place to stay in Rafah. Yes, yes, you can come, Yousef told him. One more tent.
然后他去了市场寻找药物，因为他的妻子马纳尔病了。没能找到药。在这期间，他又接到另一个正在逃难亲戚的电话，需要在拉法找个地方住。优素福告诉他：“行，行，你可以过来。”又多了一个帐篷。
Near his sister's tents, Yousef saw a guy building a bathroom, hired that guy, but he's busy until tomorrow. The bathroom guy told Yousef he needed to find supplies. So Yousef spent hours searching for cement, stones, and a water tank. He found a water tank, but it was in a different part of Gaza. So Yousef paid more than the price of the water tank to get it transported.
在他姐妹帐篷附近，优素福看到一个正在盖厕所的人，雇了那个人，但他忙到明天才能开工。建厕所的人告诉优素福他需要寻找物资。于是优素福花了几个小时寻找水泥、石头和一个水箱。他找到了一个水箱，但它在加沙的另一边。优素福付出了比水箱本身价格还高的运费才运过来。
I was picturing like a hole in the ground that you were going to build near-- you were going to dig near the tents. But you're building an actual bathroom with water and walls.
我原以为你要在帐篷附近挖个坑。但你是在建一个带水和墙壁的真正厕所。
Yes, so that's actually, that was a condition from my sisters.
是的，这实际上是我姐妹们的要求。
So, is that the first thing for you tomorrow?
那么，这是你明天要做的第一件事吗？
Definitely, yes. It will be happening for sure tomorrow because, ya'ani, a few-- two hours ago or less, there was an airstrike near them, and it takes me half an hour or more just trying to call, trying to call. I couldn't reach anyone. That's freaking me out. And I cannot handle the situation again. And I managed to reach my sister, Aseel. And they are fine. There's a lot of gas and a lot of bombing, but we are fine. And that's what-- and this is when we agreed, hallas, tomorrow you are moving. And I will come to pick you tomorrow.
绝对是。明天肯定会完成，因为，天哪，两小时前或更早，她们附近发生了空袭，我花了半个多小时试图打电话，一直打不通。我联系不上任何人。那简直让我疯掉。我无法再应付那种情况了。我终于联系上了我的姐妹阿塞尔。她们还行。有很多瓦斯和轰炸，但我们还好。这就是为什么……就在那时我们达成一致，结束了，明天你们就搬。我明天来接你们。
Oh, you did?
哦，你这么说了？
Yeah.
是的。
So she definitely agreed.
所以她真的同意了。
Yeah, yeah. I then-- sorry. [SPEAKING ARABIC] Are we recording or something? Because my son is just annoying me.
是啊，是啊。我刚才……抱歉。[说阿拉伯语] 我们在录音吗？因为我儿子一直打扰我。
That's OK. I like hearing him. How old is he?
没关系。我喜欢听他的声音。他几岁了？
2 year and a 1/2.
两岁半。
2 and 1/2.
Ilya! [SPEAKING ARABIC] I'm just asking them to close the door. [SPEAKING ARABIC] Last night, I had to stay awake and until-- Ahmed who cannot sleep without being kissed 1,000 times on his cheeks until he sleeps. Sometimes when he feels that I'm tired of kissing him, he gives me his hand to kiss it.
伊利亚！[说阿拉伯语] 我只是让他们关上门。[说阿拉伯语] 昨晚，我得熬夜到……艾哈迈德如果不被亲上一千次脸颊就睡不着。有时当他觉得我亲累了，他会把手递给我让我亲。
So that you have it close to you?
这样你就能离它更近？
Exactly. Yeah, he likes to give me some rest sometimes. OK, you can kiss my hand. I don't know how he get this habit, but I don't mind it. And for me, it's OK. I'm really grateful for the rain. It start raining. Then that reduced the sound of bombing. And also, you can use, no, this is thunder strike. So we are lucky today. I can-- we can manipulate that, so ya'ani.
正是。是的，他有时喜欢让我休息一下。好了，你可以亲我的手。我不知道他怎么养成这个习惯的，但我不在意。对我来说，没问题。我很感激这场雨。开始下雨了，雨声减弱了轰炸的声音。而且，你可以利用……不，这是雷声。所以我们今天很幸运。我能……我们可以利用这一点，所以，天哪。
So you'll tell them in the night, if they hear a noise--
所以如果晚上听到声音，你会告诉她们……
Yeah, it's raining. It's raining. It's raining. You know, it's a thunder strike. It's raining, ya'ani. I don't know. At the beginning, it was a bit easy to convince them that this is fireworks or thunder strike, but then even my daughter, Illya, which is five years old, now can understand that this is airstrike. Even my son, Ahmed, who is 2 years and 1/2, and he can say like a bombing. This is from airplane. And he keep using this word gussuff, gussuff which means strikes. And-- what the hell? That's another massive airstrike.
是的，这是下雨。下雨了。下雨了。你知道，这是雷声。下雨了，天哪。我不知道。起初，说服她们这是烟火或雷声还挺容易的，但后来连我五岁的女儿伊利亚，现在也能听出来那是空袭。连两岁半的儿子艾哈迈德，都能说出那是轰炸。这是从飞机上投下的。他一直在用这个词“gussuff”，意思是打击。然后……搞什么？又是一次大规模空袭。
Is it close to you?
离你很近吗？
Uh, no. If it was close, you would hear it.
呃，不。如果很近，你就会听到了。
OK, OK.
好的，好的。
I failed to convince them that this is not a war. And I felt that they know that this is a war at that age. And they see how we are shouting. My sisters are crying, or it's not enough anymore for my children, when they feel panic from bombing, to run towards us. They start scream without even running towards us because, somehow, they understood that we don't have that ability to protect them.
我没能说服她们这不是战争。我感觉到她们在这个年纪就知道这是战争。她们看到我们在大喊大叫。我的姐妹们在哭，当我的孩子们在轰炸中感到惊慌时，只跑向我们已经不够了。她们开始尖叫，甚至不去跑向我们，因为不知何故，她们明白了我们没有保护她们的能力。
And that's something really awful when you understand that your children understand that you cannot protect them. When I start to feel useless in front of my children and I found that I cannot protect my children, I deeply regret it because--
当你明白你的孩子知道你无法保护他们时，那真的很可怕。当我开始在孩子面前感到自己没用，发现无法保护他们时，我深感后悔，因为……
You regret what?
你后悔什么？
What is the meaning as a father? I regret having children here. What is the meaning for me as a father if I cannot protect them?
作为父亲的意义是什么？我后悔把孩子带到这里。如果我无法保护他们，我作为父亲还有什么意义？
You regret having children? Having children in Gaza?
你后悔生了孩子？在加沙生了孩子？
Yes. Definitely, I regret. I made them. I made that decision. And I had children in Gaza while I know the consequences, but I wasn't imagining that we will go through this. Because I am a man of responsibility. I'm responsible for these children to secure their life and future. If I know that they will live through this, I would never, ever even get married here.
是的。绝对后悔。是我生了他们。是我做出的决定。我在知道后果的情况下在加沙有了孩子，但我没预料到我们会经历这些。因为我是一个有责任心的人。我有责任确保这些孩子的生命和未来。如果我知道他们会经历这些，我绝不会，绝不会在这里结婚。
You would never get married. Is that what you said?
你说你绝不会结婚。你是这么说的吗？
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
Yeah. Is a part of that feeling like I should have known not to do this, or--
是，那种感觉有一部分像是“我早该知道不该这么做”，或者……
It's I should never have did that decision.
是我绝不应该做出那个决定。
[PHONE DIALING]
[电话拨号声]
Hello?
你好？
Hi, Yousef. Do you have a couple of minutes?
嗨，优素福。你有几分钟时间吗？
Yeah, yeah. Of course, yeah.
是的，是的。当然，有。
How did today go?
今天过得怎么样？
Oof, it was really, really long day. Had to start really early, and it was a lot of things to do.
呼，那真是非常、非常漫长的一天。一大早就得开始，要做的事太多了。
Did they move?
她们搬了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
They moved?
她们搬了？
So I brought them all. Yeah, they moved.
所以我把她们都接过来了。是的，她们搬了。
Wow, you did it. Took you--
哇，你做到了。花了你……
Oof, it was really a lot. [LAUGHS] Last night, they were texting me about a lot of bombing. The house next to them was bombed. Another house behind them was bombed. And so they wanted to move. They wanted to go at last.
呼，那真是太多了。[笑] 昨晚，她们给我发短信说轰炸很严重。她们隔壁的房子被炸了。她们身后另一栋房子也被炸了。所以她们想搬。她们终于想走了。
Yousef, the house next to them was bombed last night?
优素福，昨晚她们隔壁的房子被炸了？
Yes. Yeah, last night was a bit harsh when they started texting me that the bombing is around us. What?
是的。昨晚当她们给我发短信说轰炸就在周围时，情况有点艰难。什么？
Yeah. But there was an airstrike that hit a property right next to them.
是的。但有一枚空袭炸弹击中了她们隔壁的建筑。
Yes, but it's a drone strike. So, OK, we have different types of missiles that the Israelis are using. So there is the F-16, which is warplanes and this American-made weapon that are destroying entire neighborhoods. The drones have smaller bombs that destroy a house or half of the house. They were afraid that the bombing might be in the same house because it's four floors, and they are on the first one. So that's why they didn't argue me and like, yes, let's move.
是的，那是无人机袭击。我们要知道，以色列人使用的导弹种类繁多。有F-16战机使用的，是美制武器，正在摧毁整个街区。无人机有较小的炸弹，摧毁一栋房子或半栋房子。她们担心轰炸可能会发生在同一栋楼，因为那是四层楼，她们住在第一层。所以这就是为什么她们没跟我争论，直接说：“是的，搬吧。”
Did you think about going in the night?
你有想过连夜过去吗？
Yeah, I told them I'm coming.
有，我告诉她们我过来了。
You texted back, I'm coming?
你回复短信说“我过来了”？
Yes, and they were freaking out that I will come. And my wife prevented me. My sisters were texting me, do not come. There is a lot of bombing in the street in front of the house. Do not come.
是的，她们当时吓坏了，怕我会过来。我妻子阻止了我。我的姐妹们给我发短信说：“别过来。房子前面的街道上有很多轰炸。别过来。”
Yousef waited till the sun came up and then drove to Khan Yunis. He says on his way there, he could hear gunfire and explosions all around him.
优素福等到太阳升起，然后开车去汗尤尼斯。他说在去那里的路上，他能听到周围的枪声和爆炸声。
The first thing I did in the morning is, I went there, pack up in the car my sisters and their children. And then I came, and then I sent another car, like a small van, small bus, so I can have the bags and everything and my brothers-in-law.
我早上做的第一件事就是开车过去，把姐妹们和她们的孩子装进车里。然后我过来了，接着我派了另一辆车，像小货车、小巴，这样我就能装下行李和所有的东西，还有我的姐夫们。
Was there a part of you that felt a little frustrated, like I told you guys you should have come earlier? I didn't want it to get to this.
你内心有没有感到一点挫败，像是“我告诉过你们应该早点过来。我不想让事情发展到这一步。”
That's exactly the first thing I said today when I met them.
那正是我今天见到她们说的第一句话。
[LAUGHS] That was how you greeted them?
[笑] 这就是你迎接她们的方式？
Yeah.
是的。
What did you say?
你说了什么？
And the first thing was like, I told you. 'Cause it was a lot of bombing, a lot of tanks. Like, I told you before. We don't need to run away under shelling and bombing. But now we did it. Khalas. Every time it had to be the same situation.
第一句就是：“我告诉过你们了。”因为当时有很多轰炸，很多坦克。“就像我之前说的。我们不需要在炮火和轰炸下逃亡。但现在我们还是这样做了。”天哪。每次都得是同样的情况。
So, overnight, you're worried about their survival, and you're panicked, and you want to drive to get them in the middle of the night. But in the morning, you greet them with, "I told you so." This is what I said was going to happen.
所以，整晚你都在担心她们的生存，惊慌失措，想在半夜开车去接她们。但早上，你迎接她们的第一句话是“我早就告诉过你们了”。这就是我说的会发生的事情。
Yeah. I was blaming them. So there is no discussion. We are leaving.
是的。我在责怪她们。所以没有讨论余地。我们要离开。
So you didn't like hug them and cry and say, I'm so glad you survived. You said, get in the car.
所以你没有拥抱她们、哭着说“我很高兴你们活下来了”。你说的是“上车”。
No, no, we have a different type of relation. It's not about hugging them. I was laughing. You should have died. I should be in the morgue now. [CHUCKLES] This is how I am with my sisters.
不，不，我们的关系方式不同。不是那种拥抱。我在笑。“你们本该死了。我现在应该在停尸房了。”[笑] 我和姐妹们就是这样相处的。
And did they laugh? What did they say?
她们笑了吗？她们说了什么？
Hadir was like, ah, you know. Actually, they will start to give me orders quickly. You need to talk to our cousin, Amajid, because he was hosting us. You need to invite him. You have to talk to him nicely and push to bring them with us because they take care of us for a long time. Now we have to repay them.
哈迪尔说：“啊，你知道的。”其实，她们很快就会开始给我下达指令。你需要和我们的堂兄阿马吉德谈谈，因为是他收留了我们。你需要邀请他。你必须礼貌地和他谈谈，并敦促他带着家人和我们一起走，因为他们照顾我们很长时间了。现在我们得报答他们。
Also, go to our Uncle Ayman because they wanted to have invited by you, not us. It's a bit weird. Like, OK, I'll do this. And you pack the luggage, and you do that. And they refused to leave before cleaning everything.
还有，去见我们的叔叔艾曼，因为他们希望被你邀请，而不是我们。这有点奇怪。我就说：“好吧，我会办的。你们去打包行李，做那个吧。”而且她们拒绝在打扫完之前离开。
They wouldn't leave without cleaning the house?
她们不打扫干净就不离开房子？
Yep, cleaning the house, kitchen, bathrooms,
是的，打扫房子、厨房、厕所。
Even though you're fleeing bombing?
尽管你们正在逃离轰炸？
Yes, because they will-- yeah, yeah, that was actually weird from them. But this is how they think, and I really respect it because we leave it better than the way we have. This is how we show respect. And we had to clean.
是的，因为她们会……是的，是的，那确实很奇怪。但这就是她们的想法，我真的很尊重这一点，因为我们离开时会让它比我们住的时候更好。这就是我们表达尊重的方式。我们不得不打扫。
And then you left.
然后你们离开了。
Yeah.
是的。
OK.
好的。
Then we left.
然后我们离开了。
What did it--
感觉……
And so it was the first time for them since the beginning of the war to see the sea.
所以那是她们自战争开始以来第一次看到大海。
Oh.
噢。
And they were very, very excited and happy.
她们非常、非常兴奋和高兴。
How did they respond to the tents when you showed them where they're staying?
当她们看到自己要住的地方时，她们对帐篷有什么反应？
I was expecting that they will be like, ah, it's not nice. It's whatever. But they were happy. It's like, OK, it's nice. It's good.
我原本以为她们会说：“啊，不好看。随便吧。”但她们很高兴。就像：“好的，不错。挺好的。”
Did you feel nervous?
你感到紧张吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I want them to see that-- to prove for them that I did my best. And I was checking on them inside the tents. What do you think? It's warm. There is two layers for the tent, one for if it's rain and one inside. I was trying to convince them as you know these sale people who is trying to convince you to buy something?
是的，是的，是的。我希望她们看到……向她们证明我已尽力。我一直在帐篷里检查她们。你们觉得怎么样？这里很暖和。帐篷有两层，一层防雨，一层在里面。我试图说服她们，你知道那些推销员吗？那些试图说服你买东西的人？
Uh-huh. That was you?
呃，那个人是你？
That's exactly what I was. That was me today. Yeah, no, it's nice. Good. We'll do with the bathroom here. We'll get something there. Here, we can turn on the fire. And I was like, oh, well, maybe I'll get you internet tomorrow. And I will get you lights here. Our neighbors have a solar panel. He will connect us some lights. Yeah, I was trying-- I was doing that salesman. And they were happy.
那正是我的写照。今天就是我。是的，不，这很不错。好的。我们在这儿弄个厕所。我们在那儿弄点东西。在这儿，我们可以点火。我当时就说：“噢，好吧，也许明天我给你们弄个网络。我会给你们安个灯。”我们的邻居有太阳能板。他会给我们接上灯。是的，我当时正在努力……我正在当那个推销员。她们很高兴。
They were? Did they give you the response you wanted?
她们真的高兴？她们给了你想要的反应吗？
Yeah, it's like, yeah, it's nice. Also, in our way coming, we went through one of the camps that people are just building tents in the streets. And they saw how miserable the situation is. And I meant to go there before taking them to our place.
是的，就像：“是的，挺好的。”而且，在我们过来的路上，我们路过了一个人们在街上建帐篷的营地。她们看到了情况是多么悲惨。我是特意经过那里才带她们去我们地方的。
You did it on purpose?
你是故意的？
Exactly, because I want them to see how people are living to prove for them that I did my best, managing what I could. When I met them today, I found out that they didn't eat for two days. They only eat rice. So first thing I was thinking about preparing a really big meal for them, and they were surprised. I had barbecues and kebab. And I was like, no, no, no.
正是，因为我希望她们看看人们是怎么生活的，向她们证明我已经尽力了，尽我所能地打理好一切。今天见到她们时，我发现她们两天没吃饭了。她们只吃大米。所以我首先想到的是给她们准备一顿真正丰盛的餐食，她们很惊喜。我有烧烤和烤肉。我说：“不，不，不。”
So they had a meal? You had a meal together?
所以她们吃了一顿餐？你们一起吃了？
A very big one. It was very expensive one, but I was like, OK, I'll feed you until you've had more than enough. [LAUGHS]
很大的一顿。非常贵，但我心想：“好的，我会喂到你们吃饱为止。”[笑]
Wow.
哇。
And so, after fasting for two days, it was to provide them with something really good.
所以，在禁食两天之后，给她们提供一些真正好吃的东西。
Did they appreciate it?
她们感激吗？
Ooh, a lot. They were very happy. I was very happy also, having this meal.
噢，非常。她们很高兴。我也非常高兴，能有这顿饭。
The next day, Yousef went to work, his family getting settled right nearby. He made it a couple hours into the day when he got a call from his youngest sister, Aseel.
第二天，优素福去工作，家人在附近安顿下来。他刚工作了几个小时，就接到了小妹妹阿塞尔的电话。
It's too complicated.
太复杂了。
Wait, tell me what happened with your sister.
等等，告诉我你姐妹发生了什么事。
So Aseel today wanted to go to the bathroom, and she waited. So there is in the land next to us, they have a bathroom and they are friends of mine. And my neighbor is hosting more than 60 people. So they have to wait in line to earn this bathroom. It's a single bathroom.
所以阿塞尔今天想去上厕所，她等了。我们旁边有一块地，那里有个厕所，那是我的朋友。我的邻居收留了超过60人。所以她们必须排队才能用到这个厕所。这是一个单间厕所。
Oh, wow.
噢，哇。
[SIGHS] Well, yes, and she cannot wait. She is pregnant and ya'ani. It's a bit embarrassing for her. And so she started to cry, and then she called me.
[叹气] 好吧，是的，她等不及了。她怀孕了，天哪。这对她来说有点尴尬。所以她开始哭，然后打电话给我。
While she was in line?
在她排队的时候？
So she tried several times, and she was hopeless. Then she started to cry and decided to go back to Khan Yunis.
她试了几次，绝望了。然后她开始哭，决定回汗尤尼斯。
[GASPS]
[喘息]
She decided that, and she called me and she told me, I am leaving to Khan Yunis now. Oh, that changed the day. I had to go back to meet my sister, take her to the bathroom, spend an hour or more. I stopped the line.
她决定那样做，她打电话告诉我，我现在要回汗尤尼斯了。噢，那改变了这一天。我不得不回去找我的姐妹，带她去厕所，花了一个多小时。我暂停了排队。
How did the 60 people waiting respond to that?
那排队的60人有什么反应？
Ah, it went OK. I told them no one is getting inside. No one goes to the bathroom, hallas, until my sister finished.
啊，还行。我告诉他们没人能进去。没人去厕所，结束了，直到我姐妹用完为止。
Was she seriously thinking about going back to Khan Yunis?
她真的在考虑回汗尤尼斯吗？
I don't think so. It shows me that she needs me. I need to find a solution now. She's above the limit.
我不这么认为。这向我表明她需要我。我现在必须找到一个解决方案。她已经超出极限了。
How pregnant is she? When is she due?
她怀孕多久了？预产期是什么时候？
That's another alarming thing. So she is at the seventh month, about to finish it. So I guess she is going [SIGHS] through a lot.
那是另一件令人担心的事。她怀孕七个月了，快结束了。所以我猜她[叹气]经历了很多。
The whole week, Yousef had been telling me he needed his family close to him. Now, they're here. They're together in Rafah. They'd moved from the very north of Gaza all the way down, at the bottom edge of the Gaza Strip on the border with Egypt. Yousef was now responsible for his own camp of about 60 people, one of whom was eight months pregnant, and all of whom were looking to him to tell them, what now? What's the plan?
整个星期，优素福一直在告诉我他需要家人们靠近他。现在，她们在这儿了。她们都在拉法。她们从加沙最北端一路南下，到达加沙地带的最边缘，与埃及接壤。优素福现在负责他自己的营地，约60人，其中一人怀孕八个月，所有人都看着他，想让他告诉他们：“现在怎么办？计划是什么？”
Chana Joffe-Walt. Coming up, things do not go like Yousef planned. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特。接下来，事情并没有像优素福计划的那样发展。芝加哥公共广播电台的节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today, we're telling the story of Yousef Hammash. He spent months moving his family from one place to another in Gaza, trying to keep them safe. Until, finally, at the end of last year, he got them out of Rafah, an enormous feat that-- I don't want to idealize Yousef here, but there are few people who have the special combination of resources and familial relationships and trust and also skills and planning abilities and really luck to pull off what Yousef just pulled off-- getting 60 people to Rafah housed and together and seemingly, for the moment, safe.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，我们在讲述优素福·哈马什的故事。他花了几个月时间带着家人在加沙从一个地方搬到另一个地方，试图保护他们。直到最后，去年年底，他把她们带出了拉法，这是一个巨大的壮举——我不想在这里理想化优素福，但很少有人具备这种特殊的能力组合：资源、亲情信任、规划技能，以及真的运气，去完成优素福刚刚完成的事情——让60个人在拉法安顿下来并在一起，而且目前看来很安全。
So, by the beginning of this year, they're all settled in Rafah, waiting. But every day, there's talk that Israel is going to launch a ground assault in Rafah next. And Aseel, Yousef's youngest sister, is about to give birth. Again, here's Chana.
所以，今年年初，她们都在拉法安顿下来，等待着。但每天都有传言说以色列下一步将在拉法发动地面袭击。而优素福最小的姐妹阿塞尔，快要分娩了。再次请听查娜的报道。
I really wanted to talk to Yousef's sister, Aseel. Once he got them all to Rafah, she was the one Yousef was thinking about the most, talked about the most. The funny sister, the emotional sister. Also the one most like Yousef-- resourceful, determined. Yousef told me once Aseel settled in Rafah, she quickly started taking things into her own hands.
我真的很想和优素福的姐妹阿塞尔谈谈。一旦他把她们都带到拉法，她就是优素福最挂念的人。有趣的姐妹，感性的姐妹。也是和优素福最像的一个——足智多谋，意志坚定。优素福曾经告诉我，阿塞尔在拉法安顿下来后，很快就开始自己动手解决问题。
First of all, the tents Yousef built, they were too crowded and loud. Aseel built her own tent with her husband. Every time Yousef went to visit the camp, he'd find everyone in Aseel's tent, hanging out. She began to rebuild other parts of her life there, too. Aseel is a nurse. People in the camp began bringing her their medical questions. She'd advise, follow up, try to source medications for them when she could. Aseel's tent became part living room, part clinic.
首先，优素福盖的帐篷太拥挤吵闹了。阿塞尔和她丈夫盖了自己的帐篷。每次优素福去探望营地，都会发现所有人都聚在阿塞尔的帐篷里。她也开始在那儿重建生活的其他部分。阿塞尔是一名护士。营地里的人开始带着医疗问题找她咨询。她会建议、跟进，尽力在有条件时获取药物。阿塞尔的帐篷成了客厅兼诊所。
Yousef had always told me Aseel was his youngest and most stubborn sister. But when she arrived in Rafah, he added, she's also the least fazed. Difficult things do not rattle Aseel, which is why the moment she'd called him, crying in line to the bathroom, was so alarming to him.
优素福一直告诉我阿塞尔是他最小、最固执的姐妹。但当她到达拉法时，他补充说，她也是最从容的一个。困难的事情不会让阿塞尔动摇，这就是为什么她给他打电话、在厕所排队时哭泣的那一刻，让他如此震惊。
Yeah, she usually doesn't complain. She doesn't complain. Usually, Aseel is the most-- between my sister, I look to Aseel as the most wise. She's young, but she's expert. She's in love with nursing and all of this. She reads a lot. I spoke a lot about Aseel. And trust me, you'll be surprised when you talk to her.
是的，她通常不抱怨。她不抱怨。通常，在我的姐妹中，我认为阿塞尔是最睿智的。她很年轻，但她是专家。她热爱护理工作。她读很多书。我谈过很多关于阿塞尔的事。相信我，当你和她交谈时，你会感到惊讶。
It was really hard to reach Aseel.
联系到阿塞尔真的很难。
Hello?
你好？
Hi, Aseel. This is Chana.
嗨，阿塞尔。我是查娜。
Hi finally.
嗨，终于联系上了。
Hi, finally the famous sister.
嗨，终于联系到那位著名的姐妹了。
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
[笑] 是的。
The internet is OK now?
网络现在可以吗？
Erm, yeah.
呃，可以。
OK. Did I lose you?
好的。我没听清？
It was not OK.
刚才不行。
The internet is really bad. Uh, one minute, please.
网络真的很烂。嗯，请等一分钟。
OK, OK.
好的，好的。
The was no internet at the tents and hardly any cell connection. I'd try catch Aseel on the internet at Yousef's office or on her phone.
帐篷那边没有网络，几乎没有手机信号。我试着在优素福的办公室网络上或她的手机上联系阿塞尔。
Hi, Chana.
嗨，查娜。
Hi. Can you hear me?
嗨。能听到我吗？
Yeah.
可以。
OK.
好的。
We will try.
我们会试试的。
OK, OK.
好的，好的。
I learned things in scraps of conversation that were maybe two or three minutes long, some voice memos, text messages. Just as Aseel had managed her situation at the camp, she took control of her plans for childbirth, too.
我通过一些可能只有两三分钟长的支离破碎的对话、一些语音备忘录和短信了解了事情。正如阿塞尔在营地处理自己的状况一样，她也掌控了自己分娩的计划。
Aseel told me she'd never been fearful of childbirth. She'd seen lots of births as a nurse. She was actually working in labor and delivery in Gaza City when the war started. She'd imagined it. She could do it. She said, when it comes to health care matters, I'm capable of controlling the situation for myself and those around me.
阿塞尔告诉我她从不害怕分娩。作为护士，她见过很多分娩。战争开始时，她实际上正在加沙城的产房工作。她想象过。她能做到。她说：“在医疗保健方面，我有能力为自己和周围的人控制局面。”
When she had to flee her home, leave behind the doctor she loved and the hospital she had planned to deliver in, Aseel just made a new plan. She found a new hospital and a new doctor in Khan Yunis. When that fell apart and she fled to Rafah, Aseel brought Yousef into her planning process.
当她不得不逃离家园，丢下她心爱的医生和她原计划分娩的医院时，阿塞尔只是制定了一个新计划。她在汗尤尼斯找了一家新医院和一位新医生。当那一切破灭，她逃到拉法时，阿塞尔把优素福也拉进了她的规划过程。
In Rafah, Aseel and Yousef worked in tandem. They figured out where she could deliver-- a small maternity hospital. They mapped out a route to the hospital. Rafah is so packed with traffic and people now, it can take hours to get across the city, so Yousef studied routes and Google Maps. And he practiced driving to the hospital on back streets through farmland and bumpy dirt roads.
在拉法，阿塞尔和优素福协作。她们找出她在哪里分娩——一家小型妇产医院。她们规划了一条去医院的路线。拉法现在交通拥堵、人满为患，跨越城市可能需要几个小时，所以优素福研究了路线和谷歌地图。他还练习通过农田和颠簸的泥土路走后路开车去医院。
Aseel didn't want to bring a newborn back to the tent in the cold, so Yousef asked the NRC if Aseel and the baby could stay with him and the other staff living at the NRC office, just for a bit after the birth. They said yes.
阿塞尔不想带新生儿回寒冷的帐篷，所以优素福请求NRC允许阿塞尔和婴儿在分娩后和住在NRC办公室的其他员工呆在一起一段时间。他们同意了。
At the camp, they got the bathroom up and running four days after Aseel arrived. By late January, Yousef and Aseel had a bathroom, a route to the hospital, and a postpartum plan. There was only one thing Aseel desperately wanted that she couldn't make happen herself. She told me in Arabic, when we were finally able to talk for a longer stretch.
在营地，阿塞尔到达四天后，他们就把厕所建好了。到一月下旬，优素福和阿塞尔有了厕所、去医院的路线，还有一个产后计划。阿塞尔拼命想要的一件事是她自己无法实现的。她在我终于能和她长时间交谈时用阿拉伯语告诉我。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
I've always prayed that I won't give birth until there's a truce. I don't want to start experiencing labor pain before there's a truce. God willing, it will happen.
我一直祈祷在停火前不要分娩。我不想在停火前开始经历分娩阵痛。愿真主保佑，这会发生的。
Every day, there were small glimmers of a possible truce. Negotiations were underway for a ceasefire between Israel and Hamas. It was the last week of January. Aseel was due February 4. With or without a truce, Aseel and Yousef had a plan.
每天都有可能停火的微弱迹象。以色列和哈马斯之间正在进行停火谈判。那是一月的最后一周。阿塞尔的预产期是2月4日。无论是否停火，阿塞尔和优素福都有个计划。
Then, five days before her due date, they had an unexpected dry run that tested their plan. Aseel had contractions in the middle of the night. Yousef raced her to the hospital. It was a false alarm. The contractions subsided. But for the first time, Aseel got to see what it looked like inside the hospital.
然后，在预产期前五天，她们进行了一次意外的预演，考验了她们的计划。阿塞尔半夜阵痛。优素福开车送她去了医院。那是一次虚惊。阵痛消退了。但这是阿塞尔第一次看到医院内部的情况。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
When you enter the hospital, there's an unimaginable number of displaced people. It's full of displaced people. When we were standing at the door, there was a woman coming from Abasan in Khan Yunis. They were displaced, and she came to the hospital in labor. Her water had already broken. She was standing at the door, waiting in line, because there are five or six beds inside, and they are all full. She was waiting for her turn to get examined, even though she couldn't stand. The baby came out while she was waiting at the door.
当你进入医院时，里面有数不清的流离失所者。到处都是人。当我们站在门口时，有一个从汗尤尼斯的阿巴桑来的女人。她们流离失所，而她正要分娩来到医院。她的羊水已经破了。她站在门口排队等待，因为里面只有五六个床位，而且都满了。尽管她站不住了，她还是在等轮到她检查。还没进去，孩子在门口就生出来了。
You saw her give birth, Aseel?
你亲眼看到她生孩子，阿塞尔？
Yeah. The baby is all--
是的。孩子……
Yeah, the baby is all-- the baby came out, and they laid her down on the floor to deliver the baby right there. There were no beds, not even in the maternity ward. They laid her down on the floor, and the midwife or the doctor came to deliver the baby with her on the ground.
是的，婴儿……孩子出来了，他们把她放在地板上就在那里分娩。没有床位，甚至在产科病房也没有。他们把她放在地板上，助产士或医生就在地上给她接生。
Oh, wow. In front of you.
噢，哇。在你面前。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
Yeah, I feared that I would be in her place. I imagined myself in her place, waiting for my turn to go in for labor, but then for it to happen at the door.
是的，我担心我会落到她的下场。我把自己想象成她，在排队等待分娩，结果却在门口发生。
That night, in the hospital, everything suddenly felt very real to Aseel. She was about to give birth in a tiny hospital that used to have around 20 births a day, and now sometimes had 100. She would be delivering her first baby in a city that had 200,000 people just a few months ago and now had 1.5 million.
那天晚上在医院，一切突然对阿塞尔来说显得非常真实。她快要在一个小医院分娩了，那个医院过去每天约有20例分娩，而现在有时多达100例。她将在一个几个月前只有20万人，而现在有150万人的城市里生下她的第一个孩子。
She was about to give birth in a hospital in the middle of a war that had killed 600 people inside medical facilities and obliterated the vast majority of health care services. She was about to have a child in a war where more than 10,000 children have been killed so far.
她即将在战争中一家医院分娩，战争已经导致医疗设施内600人死亡，摧毁了绝大多数医疗服务。她即将在一个已有超过1万名儿童死亡的战争中生下孩子。
Aseel couldn't get unpregnant. She could pray for a ceasefire, but she couldn't wait for one. Aseel had imagined her birth so clearly before the war. But now she was imagining it in ways she never had before. What if she delivered at the hospital on the floor? What if she delivered in her tent alone? What if Israeli tanks came into Rafah while she was in labor? What if she was naked, pushing a baby out, when an Israeli soldier showed up at the door to her tent?
阿塞尔没法“不怀孕”。她可以祈祷停火，但她不能等待。战前阿塞尔清楚地想象过她的分娩。但现在她以从未有过的方式在想象。如果她在医院地板上分娩怎么办？如果她独自在帐篷里分娩怎么办？如果她在阵痛中以色列坦克进入拉法怎么办？如果当以色列士兵出现在帐篷门口时她正赤身裸体分娩怎么办？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
Thinking about this by itself plants terror in my heart. That I could give birth and see the soldiers. The mere sight of the soldiers scares me.
想到这一点本身就在我的心里种下了恐惧。我可以分娩并看到士兵。光是看到士兵就让我害怕。
And what if after she delivered her baby, she started bleeding? One horrifying thing Aseel knew was happening in Gaza right now is women who hemorrhage after birth are sometimes being given hysterectomies. I've talked to doctors and a midwife in Gaza who told me this is happening. It's happening for lots of reasons.
如果她生完孩子开始大出血怎么办？阿塞尔知道现在加沙正在发生的一件可怕的事情是，产后大出血的妇女有时被迫接受子宫切除术。我和加沙的医生和助产士谈过，他们告诉我这正在发生。原因很多。
Hospitals don't have the routine medications that help stop bleeding after birth. They also don't have staff. The staff they do have don't have time. Pregnant women are coming in malnourished, sometimes with injuries and other complications. And they're going into labor severely anemic. So, if they hemorrhage after birth, which happens sometimes, things quickly become life threatening. They're using hysterectomies in Gaza because hysterectomies can be the fastest and safest way to save lives.
医院没有帮助产后止血的常规药物。他们也没有人员。有的人也没有时间。孕妇营养不良，有时伴有伤势和其他并发症。她们严重贫血进入分娩。所以，如果她们产后大出血——有时会发生——情况很快就会危及生命。他们在加沙使用子宫切除术，因为切除子宫可能是挽救生命最快、最安全的方式。
Of all the very real possibilities Aseel was now imagining, this was the one she feared the most. She'd deliver her baby, start bleeding, and they'd take her uterus. That night in the hospital, she begged a doctor for his attention. Is it safe here? I'm a medical professional, she said. Please help me. The doctor told her, if you can deliver somewhere else, you should. Aseel walked out of the hospital to the car where Yousef was waiting and told him, I cannot have my baby here.
在阿塞尔现在想象的所有可能性中，这是她最害怕的一个。她生下孩子，开始出血，然后医生切除了她的子宫。那天晚上在医院，她恳求医生关注她。“这里安全吗？我是医务专业人士，”她说，“请帮帮我。”医生告诉她：“如果你能在别处分娩，你应该去。”阿塞尔走出医院，来到优素福等待的车里，告诉他：“我不能在这儿生孩子。”
I could see it in her eyes today. I don't think I have the capacity to translate into English what she was saying, but it's related to medical stuff that he saw with other females there. So I was like, no, I'll find a solution. Tomorrow, I'll figure it out.
今天我从她眼中看到了。我想我没有能力将她所说的翻译成英语，但这涉及到他在那儿看到的其他女性的医疗问题。所以我说：“不，我会找到解决方案的。明天，我会想办法。”
Yousef began calling people he knew, asking about other options for delivering a baby in Rafah, maybe a private doctor who could deliver outside the hospital. But those conversations quickly became other conversations. His coworkers, friends, said, but Yousef, are you seeing this? Did you see what Yoav Gallant just said, the Israeli Defense minister? He's saying Rafah is next.
优素福开始给熟人打电话，询问在拉法分娩的其他选择，也许是一名可以在医院外接生的私立医生。但那些对话很快变成了其他话题。他的同事、朋友说：“但优素福，你看到了吗？你看到约阿夫·加兰特，以色列国防部长刚才说的话了吗？他说拉法是下一个。”
Gallant, Yoav Gallant, who said that when we finish from Khan Yunis, we will go into Rafah. And that's a huge concern. For example, from where I am staying, the Israeli tanks in Al-Aqsa University, it's less than 1 kilometer. I can hear the tanks moving clearly. I can hear the clashes clearly. And I think if the Israelis decided to continue the ground operation in Rafah, it's going to take them three minutes to arrive me.
加兰特，约阿夫·加兰特，他说等我们结束汗尤尼斯的行动后，就会进入拉法。这是一个巨大的担忧。例如，从我住的地方看，以色列坦克在阿克萨大学，距离不到一公里。我可以清晰地听到坦克移动的声音。我能清晰地听到冲突的声音。我认为如果以色列决定在拉法继续地面行动，他们只需要三分钟就能抵达我这里。
When Yousef thinks of those three minutes, he's not just thinking of himself. He's thinking of the 60 people he moved from other parts of Gaza to here. He's thinking how he promised this was the safest place to be.
当优素福想到那三分钟时，他不仅是在想他自己。他是在想他从加沙其他地方带到这里的60个人。他是在想他如何保证这是最安全的地方。
Building that camp, hosting these families, and then if the Israelis decided to start the ground operation in Rafah, it's going to be like an ambush. It's going to be like, I create an ambush for these families, bringing families to live in that place, and the Israelis killing. I don't know, you know.
搭建那个营地，收留这些家庭，如果以色列决定在拉法开始地面行动，那将像一场伏击。就像是，我为这些家庭制造了一场伏击，把家庭带到那个地方居住，而以色列人正在杀戮。我不知道，你知道。
It's going to be on you.
这会算在你头上。
Yes, at least I will feel it on me. Also, their relatives, their father-in-laws, all of them I'm hosting them in the camp I build. So I'm also responsible, at least, to inform these families that it's not safe here. I remember what happened in Khan Yunis also. And they would start talking about Khan Yunis, and they destroyed the entire city.
是的，至少我会觉得是我的责任。而且，他们的亲戚，他们的公公，所有我收留在我搭的营地里的人。所以我也有责任，至少告知这些家庭这里不安全。我还记得在汗尤尼斯发生的事情，他们摧毁了整个城市。
I know. I can't believe you're in this situation again. This is exactly where you were when we talked--
我知道。我无法相信你又处于这种情况。这和你我们谈话时完全一样——
Exactly.
完全一样。
--in early December.
——在十二月初。
[SIGHS] Now that's a long time. That's a long time.
[叹气] 那是很久以前的事了。那是很久以前的事了。
Are you thinking about moving again?
你在考虑再次搬迁吗？
I'll have to think about the options that I have, yeah, if we are going. And I was thinking about Deir al Balah.
我得考虑我有的选择，是的，如果我们走的话。我在考虑代尔拜拉赫。
Why Deir al Balah? Why was that a place that you looked at?
为什么是代尔拜拉赫？为什么那是你考虑的地方？
This is the only areas that considered safe by the Israelis. They said either Rafah or Deir al Balah. But today I was looking for the statistics of Deir al Balah. On a daily basis, there is at least five targeted, five houses targeted in Deir al Balah. So I have to think more twice about that. You cannot make a decision because nothing is clear.
这是唯一被以色列人认为安全的区域。他们说要么拉法，要么代尔拜拉赫。但今天我查了代尔拜拉赫的数据。每天至少有五次针对性袭击，五栋房子被针对。所以我必须三思。你无法做出决定，因为什么都不清楚。
Yeah. And did you find a doctor for Aseel?
是的。你为阿塞尔找到医生了吗？
Uh, yes.
呃，找到了。
Wow, you found a doctor already?
哇，你已经找到医生了？
Yeah.
是的。
Is it incredibly expensive?
这非常昂贵吗？
She found it. We didn't agree yet, but I told him I'll pay whatever you want. I just want her to be safe and in an appropriate place and all of that. So I don't care about financial things.
她找到了。我们还没达成一致，但我告诉他我愿意付你任何你想要的。我只是希望她安全，在适当的地方等等。所以我不在乎经济上的事情。
February 3, the day before her due date, Yousef, the private doctor, and Aseel agreed on a new plan. She would deliver at a clinic outside the hospital. The doctor promised they were equipped to deal with complications there without doing a hysterectomy. Five days later, February 8, still no baby.
2月3日，预产期前一天，优素福、私立医生和阿塞尔达成了一个新计划。她将在医院外的一家诊所分娩。医生保证他们有设备处理那里的并发症，无需切除子宫。五天后，2月8日，还没生。
February 9, the prime minister of Israel, Benjamin Netanyahu, ordered the military to develop a plan to evacuate Rafah, to clear the way for a ground assault on Rafah. That same day, I got a message from Yousef. Aseel is currently in the hospital for the birth. I called several hours later. Yousef was outside the hospital, waiting. Aseel was inside with his wife and their mom. He told me the baby had arrived. She was healthy. But he wasn't sure about his sister.
2月9日，以色列总理本杰明·内塔尼亚胡命令军方制定拉法撤离计划，为拉法地面袭击扫清障碍。同一天，我收到优素福的消息。“阿塞尔目前在医院生产。”几个小时后我打了电话。优素福在医院外面等待。阿塞尔在里面，有他妻子和他们的母亲陪着。他告诉我孩子出生了。她很健康。但他不确定他姐妹的情况。
But Aseel, she's still under watch inside. So, unfortunately, she was bleeding, so we are waiting.
但是阿塞尔，她还在医院里观察。所以，不幸的是，她在大出血，所以我们在等。
She's bleeding?
她在大出血？
She did a natural birth, but I think she had an issue, and she was bleeding. The doctors, all the doctors at the hospital were running, trying to control it. So it was-- I couldn't get inside because I will see through a small window that there are so many doctors around. And it's like, what's going on there? And he told me that she's bleeding, and they're trying to control it. And then after that, he informed me that they control it, but they have to wait a bit. Ah.
她是自然分娩，但我认为她出了问题，她在出血。医院里所有的医生都在跑，试图控制住。所以它是……我无法进去，因为我通过一扇小窗看到周围有这么多医生。像是，那里发生了什么？他告诉我她在出血，他们正试图控制它。在那之后，他通知我他们控制住了，但他们必须等一会。啊。
Where is her-- was her husband there?
她的……她丈夫在吗？
Yeah, her husband is very young, so that's why I have to be there, even, to ask for everything because Aseel was like, I want Yousef here, right? My mother and so many women are screaming around. And I cannot keep hearing her screaming. That's why I had to go out. I have to leave.
是的，她丈夫很年轻，所以这就是为什么我必须在那里，即使是去索要任何东西，因为阿塞尔说：“我想要优素福在这儿，对吧？”我的母亲和这么多妇女在周围尖叫。我无法再听她的尖叫声了。这就是为什么我不得不出去。我不得不离开。
Hello?
你好？
Hi, Aseel.
嗨，阿塞尔。
Hi, Chana.
嗨，查娜。
Hi, Mabrouk.
嗨，恭喜。
Hello. [SPEAKING ARABIC]
你好。[说阿拉伯语]
How are you doing?
你怎么样？
Thank you.
谢谢。
A week after she gave birth, I reached Aseel in Yousef's office. She was in bed with her mom and her new baby. She was incredibly weak. And she could not walk. Instead of the careful plan Aseel and Yousef made, she told me something very different happened. Her water broke in the middle of the night. They couldn't reach the private doctor. And Yousef couldn't get to Aseel quickly enough to drive her.
生产一周后，我在优素福的办公室联系到了阿塞尔。她和母亲及新生儿躺在床上。她极其虚弱。她无法走路。没有发生阿塞尔和优素福制定的周密计划，她告诉我发生了非常不同的事。半夜羊水破了。她们联系不上那位私立医生。优素福无法足够快地赶到阿塞尔身边送她去医院。
So a friend took her to exactly the place she didn't want to go-- the hospital. When she got there, she waited in the hallway, just as she feared, 12 hours in labor. She was begging for a room, a bed, for someone to help her.
所以一位朋友把她带到了她最不想去的地方——医院。到那儿时，她像担心的那样在走廊里等待，阵痛了12个小时。她恳求一个房间、一张床、有人能帮她。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
There was no room for me. There was no anesthetics, no nothing. I couldn't stand. I couldn't sit. I couldn't do anything. My sister spoke with the nurse there, and she told her I couldn't stand in line, and that I was about to give birth.
没有我的房间。没有麻醉剂，什么都没有。我站不住。我坐不下。我什么都做不了。我姐妹和那里的护士谈过，她告诉她我无法排队，我快要分娩了。
There was no chair for you to sit on?
没有椅子给你坐？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
No, no, there was no chairs at all. There was only the doctor's chair. And I took it from her.
没有，没有，根本没有椅子。只有医生的椅子。我从她那儿拿走了。
Oh.
噢。
Aseel sat in the hallway on the stolen chair for more hours, more contractions. She felt the baby's head, the need to push. Finally, they called her back, rushed her to a bed. But Aseel looked at the bed and froze.
阿塞尔在走廊里坐在偷来的椅子上又等了几个小时，更多的阵痛。她感觉到孩子的头，需要用力。终于，他们叫了她，冲进了一张床。但阿塞尔看着那张床僵住了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
The bed sheet on it was the same one the woman before me gave birth on. It was covered in blood. So I took it off and told them to get the cleaner to wipe the bed.
床单和前一个女人生产的一样。上面全是血。所以我把它拿下来，让他们找清洁工把床擦干净。
While you were in labor?
在你阵痛的时候？
Yes, yes. I couldn't sit in the bed, even with my pain. I'm willing to endure the pain a bit, but in a clean place and deliver the baby in a clean, sanitized place.
是的，是的。我无法坐在床上，即使有疼痛。我愿意忍受一点疼痛，但要在干净的地方，在干净、消过毒的地方生下孩子。
In bed, Aseel immediately had to push. She pushed, feeling utter panic, pushed and pushed without stopping, without breaks. She had an internal hemorrhage. The doctor made an incision to make the opening bigger. She bled more. The whole day, Aseel had been directing the people around her for a chair, for a clean sheet. But once the baby arrived, she lost control. The nurses took the baby. Then Aseel hemorrhaged for three hours, while doctors tried to stop the bleeding.
在床上，阿塞尔立即必须用力。她用力，感到极度的恐慌，用力再用力，没有停止，没有休息。她内出血了。医生做了一个切口使开口变大。她流了更多血。整天，阿塞尔一直在指导周围的人找椅子、找干净的床单。但孩子出生后，她失去了控制。护士抱走了孩子。然后阿塞尔大出血了三个小时，医生们试图止血。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
Five doctors came in. I couldn't stay with them. I couldn't keep my eyes open. After about an hour of stitching and 28 stitches-- there was no anesthesia or anything-- I was appealing to God, 28 stitches between internal and external. I couldn't speak back to them or tell them I couldn't-- that I was dizzy. I couldn't speak to them at all. I had surrendered to the pain. He told me that if it didn't work, they'll be forced to do a hysterectomy. I kept quiet and prayed that it wouldn't happen.
五个医生进来了。我无法和他们呆在一起。我无法睁开眼睛。在大约一小时的缝合后，缝了28针——没有麻醉剂或任何东西——我在向真主祈求，28针，包括内层和外层。我无法回答他们或告诉他们我无法……我当时头晕。我根本无法和他们说话。我已经屈服于疼痛。他告诉我如果效果不好，他们将被迫切除子宫。我保持沉默，祈祷它不会发生。
I wasn't present, but I felt the thread going in. I felt the prick of the needle. I was crying a lot and praying to God that it would be the last stitch. Every time I prayed it would be the last stitch, they told me there was one more. You're almost there. This is the last one. I couldn't wait to leave the room. I couldn't move. And I was calling for my brother, saying, I can't do it, and for someone to get me out.
我不在场，但我感觉线穿过。我感觉到了针刺。我哭得很厉害，祈祷真主这是最后一针。每次我祈祷那是最后一针，他们告诉我还有一针。你快好了。这是最后一针。我迫不及待地想离开那个房间。我动不了。我在喊我兄弟，说“我做不到”，让别人带我离开。
You were calling for Yousef?
你在喊优素福？
Yes.
是的。
Why?
为什么？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
Because he would try to control the bad things that happen to us. For me, it was like, you can help me in this matter, too. Come save me.
因为他会试图控制我们身上发生的坏事。对我来说，就像，你在这件事上也能帮我。快来救我。
Eventually, the doctors finished the stitches and gave Aseel a blood transfusion. An obstetrician practicing in Gaza told me Aseel was very lucky the hospital had blood that day. All the donated blood is from within Gaza, and most days, there's not enough. Aseel lost so much blood, she couldn't see clearly. Normally, after hemorrhaging that much, you'd stay in the hospital for a few days. It's hard to move. You're weak, in pain. There's danger of infection, fainting. She had the stitches. But Aseel was desperate to get out of there.
最终，医生完成了缝合，给阿塞尔输了血。一位在加沙执业的产科医生告诉我阿塞尔很幸运那天医院有血。所有的捐献血液都来自加沙内部，大部分日子里，都不够。阿塞尔失血过多，视线模糊。通常，大出血后，你会留在医院几天。很难移动。你很虚弱，疼痛。有感染、昏厥的危险。她缝了针。但阿塞尔迫切想离开那里。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
They told me not to leave because I couldn't get up. The stitches hurt a lot. I told them I wanted to leave because the place is not clean and because the displaced go there, so you can't get rest. Yousef came to the hospital entrance. I couldn't get myself there, so I used a chair. They didn't have a wheelchair, so I used a normal chair for support. And I walked. I took the elevator down to the car.
他们告诉我不要离开，因为我起不来。缝合处很疼。我告诉他们我想离开，因为地方不干净，流离失所的人去那儿，所以你无法休息。优素福到了医院入口。我无法自己到那儿，所以我用了一张椅子。他们没有轮椅，所以我用了一张普通的椅子作为支撑。我走了。我坐电梯下到车里。
You had to get yourself to the elevator with the help of a chair?
你不得不靠着一张椅子的支撑走到电梯？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
Yes. I used the chair to get to the elevator. And when I got down, there's a 10-meter-long hallway or something like that.
是的。我用椅子走到电梯。当我下去时，有一个10米长的走廊。
Oh, my God.
天哪。
And so I used the chair for support until I got to the car. Yousef then carried me into the car. He carried me and put me inside the car.
所以我用椅子支撑直到走到车里。然后优素福把我抱进车里。他抱起我，把我放进车里。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
I didn't even pay attention to the baby's features until I got a blood transfusion and started to feel better.
直到输血后开始感觉好点，我甚至没注意孩子的长相。
What did she look like when you were able to see her?
当你能看到她时，她长什么样？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
When I first saw her, I said she looked a lot like Yousef and his little son.
当我第一次看到她时，我说她长得非常像优素福和他的小儿子。
Oh, really? Ahmed?
噢，真的吗？艾哈迈德？
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
Did you feel happy about that?
你觉得高兴吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, it was one of the longest days of my life.
是的，那是我生命中最漫长的一天。
That picture is so beautiful of you with the baby.
那张你和孩子的照片太美了。
Yeah. When I take it, I was happy and excited. Yeah, yeah.
是的。拍的时候，我很高兴和兴奋。是的，是的。
You look much skinnier. I hope it's OK to say that.
你看起来瘦多了。希望这么说没关系。
Yeah, yeah, I lost so much weight, you know. Canned food.
是的，是的，我瘦了很多，你知道。罐头食品。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, that's fine.
是的，没关系。
Yousef said, holding the baby, he felt immense relief.
优素福说，抱着孩子，他感到了巨大的解脱。
Yeah, it reduced all that pressure that I was having for a couple of months about that moment. And finally, I reach it. It was a glimmer of hope. And I was waiting to have that feeling, all of that period, all that pressure in my head every day about Aseel's pregnancy, when she's going to do the birth, where, blah, blah, blah, all of that is over.
是的，它减轻了几个月来我关于那个时刻的所有压力。最终，我达到了。那是一丝希望。而在那整个期间，我一直在等待那种感觉，我脑子里每天关于阿塞尔怀孕的所有压力，她什么时候生，在哪生，等等等等，这一切都结束了。
He got Aseel and the baby home from the hospital, or at least, to the office that is now home, where he'd created a bed for them to share with his mom. Everyone went to sleep. That night, at 1:00 in the morning, Yousef woke up to bombing. It was louder and brighter than anything he'd experienced in Rafah before. It felt like it was right nearby, inside Rafah.
他把阿塞尔和孩子从医院接回家，或者至少接回现在作为家的办公室，在那儿他为她们铺了一张床和母亲共用。大家都睡了。那天晚上，凌晨1点，优素福在轰炸声中醒来。它比他在拉法经历过的任何声音都更响、更亮。感觉就在附近，就在拉法里面。
The house was shaking, huge bombardment. There's children screaming. And I thought that the Israelis, they start the operation, and I will find the tanks in front of my place. And that's it. I was going to-- I was about to put on my underwear because this is the way they take us men, wearing only underwear.
房子在摇晃，巨大的轰炸。有孩子在尖叫。我想以色列人开始了行动，我会在我的住处前面看到坦克。就是这样。我当时……我打算穿上内裤，因为这是他们抓我们男人的方式，只穿内裤。
Wait, why were you going to put on your underwear?
等等，你为什么要穿上内裤？
No, so, actually, I was joking, but usually, the Israelis, when they collect men, whenever they go on the ground and they collect men above 16 years old, wearing only underwear.
不，所以，其实我是在开玩笑，但通常以色列人在收集男人时，无论他们什么时候在地面上行动，他们收集16岁以上的男人时，只让他们穿内裤。
You mean they make them take off their clothes?
你是说他们让他们脱掉衣服？
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, that's a dark thought to have in the middle of the night.
噢，那是深夜里一个黑暗的想法。
Actually, I was joking. I was telling Manal, my wife, I need to prepare the underwear. It should be warm. This is part of our life experience, so sorry. Yeah, it's kind of a joke. I know it's a dark humor, but that's me.
其实，我是在开玩笑。我告诉马纳尔，我妻子，我需要准备好内裤。它应该很暖和。这是我们生活经历的一部分，所以抱歉。是的，这算是黑色幽默，但这就是我。
What did your wife say?
你妻子说什么？
It wasn't actually the right moment to make jokes. I don't usually find the right timing for to make jokes.
那其实不是开玩笑的好时机。我通常找不到开玩笑的时机。
[LAUGHS] Manal was not appreciating your joke at that moment?
[笑] 马纳尔在那一刻没有领情你的笑话？
No. No. Yeah, we had to collect the kids between us and trying to warm them and to calm them. And so we tried to get them back to sleep, but-- because nothing we can do more than that.
没有。没有。是的，我们必须把孩子聚在一起，试图温暖他们并安抚他们。所以我们试图让他们重新入睡，但……因为除了那样我们什么也做不了。
In the morning, Yousef was finally able to get online and figure out what just happened the night before. That night, Israel rescued two Israeli hostages from Rafah, two older men who'd been held captive for months since October 7.
早上，优素福终于能上网弄清楚昨晚发生了什么。那天晚上，以色列在拉法营救了两名以色列人质，两名自10月7日以来被囚禁了几个月的年长男子。
And Israel killed, according to the Gaza Health Ministry, at least 94 Palestinians. Amnesty International says half the people killed in Rafah that night were children, including a two-week-old baby girl. That was Aseel's first night out of the hospital, in bed with her mom next to her, praying through six hours of bombing and the baby crying.
根据加沙卫生部的数据，以色列杀害了至少94名巴勒斯坦人。国际特赦组织称，那天晚上在拉法被杀的人中有一半是儿童，包括一名两周大的女婴。那是阿塞尔出院后的第一晚，和母亲躺在床上，在六小时的轰炸和婴儿哭声中祈祷。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
I couldn't move or anything. I was scared. I waited for Yousef to come down in the morning and asked him if there's going to be a ground invasion in Rafah because I couldn't walk. I couldn't carry the baby and stand.
我动不了或做不了任何事。我很害怕。我等着优素福早上下来，问他拉法会不会有地面入侵，因为我无法走路。我无法抱着孩子站着。
Yeah. What did he say?
是的。他说了什么？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
He said, don't worry. That won't happen. I told him all I was worried about happened. Waiting in line in the hospital happened. The difficult labor happened. And now they are entering here? No, at least this one shouldn't happen.
他说：“别担心。那不会发生。”我告诉他我担心的所有事情都发生了。在医院排队发生了。艰难的分娩发生了。现在他们要进到这儿来了？不，至少这个不应该发生。
Are you starting to doubt his reassurances when he says, don't worry?
你开始怀疑他那句“别担心”的保证了吗？
No, for me, what he says is what happens. I believe him.
不，对我来说，他说的就是会发生的。我相信他。
Right now, there are dozens of people waiting to see what Yousef says, what he's lining up for them next. He's launched into overdrive, calling friends, colleagues, carefully parsing official statements on a possible Rafah invasion, and looking for a place they could flee to, a building that's still standing, a piece of land he can rent and build tents-- exactly what he was doing when I first called him back in early December. Only now, he's exhausted. He's skinnier. His sister just had a baby and can't walk. Yousef has been quite ill several times. And 30,000 Palestinians have been killed since the war started.
现在，有几十个人等着看优素福怎么说，看他接下来为他们安排什么。他全速运转，打电话给朋友、同事，仔细分析关于可能发生的拉法入侵的官方声明，并寻找他们可以逃离的地方，一座仍然屹立的建筑，一块他可以租下来搭帐篷的地——这正是他在十二月初第一次给我打电话时所做的事情。只是现在，他精疲力竭。他瘦了。他姐妹刚生了孩子，无法走路。优素福已经病了好几次。自战争开始以来，已有3万名巴勒斯坦人被杀害。
And it's not over. Right now, for the first time since Yousef began moving his family on October 8 to keep them safe, Yousef is not finding options. This time, there really may not be anywhere to go.
而且还没结束。现在，自10月8日优素福开始带家人搬迁以保护他们安全以来，优素福第一次找不到选择了。这一次，可能真的没有地方可去了。
Actually, to be honest, I don't want to think about that because I know there is no solution. And it's going to be just a headache to go through details, what I will do. What-- Aseel, what about Habil, what about Heba, what about Salsabeel, what about my wife and the children, my mother. And it's responsibility above responsibility. And unfortunately, this time, I'm completely useless because I ran out of options. And when I think about it deeply, there is no solution. There is no option ahead of me. So what am I going to do?
其实，说实话，我不想考虑那个，因为我知道没有解决方案。去处理细节、我去该做什么，只会让人头疼。什么……阿塞尔，还有哈比尔、赫巴、萨尔萨比尔怎么办，我妻子和孩子，我母亲怎么办。那是责任之上的责任。但不幸的是，这一次，我彻底没用了，因为我耗尽了选项。当我深入思考它时，没有解决方案。我面前没有选择。所以我该怎么办？
I have never heard you talk like that, Yousef. I've never heard you say that. You're always the guy that's like, yeah, I'll figure it out. I'll call so-and-so tomorrow. Or no, we don't have it right now, but I'll figure it out.
我从未听过你这么说，优素福。我从未听过你说过那样的话。你总是那个像是“是的，我会想办法的。我明天给某某打电话。或者不，我们现在没有，但我会想办法的”那个人。
I don't have enough resources to manage this now. It's chaotic situation. And I don't think I'm mentally stable to take a decision now. I'm trying to avoid thinking about it because I'm not prepared because I don't have solutions. I don't have options ahead of me. When I have options, I'll start to think deeply about it. But up to now, I'm completely useless.
我现在没有足够的资源来处理这个。那是混乱的情况。我不认为我现在的精神状态适合做决定。我试图避免考虑它，因为我没有准备好，因为我没有解决方案。我面前没有选择。当我有选择时，我会开始深入思考。但到目前为止，我彻底没用了。
I'm calling my friends who are, ya'ani, scattered everywhere in Gaza. And they just keep searching, but I cannot find. My friend called me several times, actually. So I need to talk to him. Maybe I can call you back after?
我正在打电话给我的朋友们，他们，天哪，分散在加沙各地。他们只是在不停地寻找，但我找不到。我的朋友其实给我打过好几次电话。所以我需要和他谈谈。也许我可以等会儿打给你？
Sure, sure.
当然，当然。
Yeah, OK, just I will try to get some news from him.
是的，好的，我只是会试着从他那儿得到些消息。
OK.
好的。
OK. Thank you, Chana. Thank you. OK.
好的。谢谢你，查娜。谢谢。好的。
Bye. Thank you.
再见。谢谢。
Bye, bye, bye.
再见，再见，再见。
Chana Joffe-Walt is one of the producers of our show. Well, our program was produced and edited today by Nancy Updike. The people who put together today's show include Jane Ackerman, Jendayi Bonds, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Katherin Rae Mondo, Saifyah Riddle, Ryan Rumery, Laura Starcheski, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特是我们节目的制作人之一。好吧，我们今天的节目由南希·厄普代克制作和编辑。今天策划节目的人员包括简·阿克曼、詹达伊·邦兹、肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、赛菲亚·里德尔、瑞安·鲁梅里、劳拉·斯塔切斯基、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman, and our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Barry. Arabic interpreters and translators and research help from Emna Zghal, Nabil Shawkat, and Hany Hawasly. Aseel's English translation was read for us by Tara Abboud. Casting help from Sabrina Hyman.
我们的执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼，高级编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·巴里。阿拉伯语口译员、翻译及研究协助来自艾姆纳·兹加尔、纳比勒·沙卡特和哈尼·哈瓦斯利。阿塞尔的英语翻译由塔拉·阿布德朗读。选角协助来自萨布丽娜·海曼。
Special thanks to Shaina Low, Anas Baba, Brian Castner, Dror Sadot, Mark Garlasco, Dr. Debbie Harrington, Dr. Tanya haj-Hassan, and Anja Bezold. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos. There's lists of favorite shows to help you find something to listen to when you want to listen to it. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
特别感谢谢娜·洛、阿纳斯·巴巴、布莱恩·卡斯特纳、德罗尔·萨多特、马克·加拉斯科、黛比·哈林顿医生、坦尼娅·哈吉-哈桑医生和安雅·贝佐尔德。我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，你可以在那里完全免费地收听我们800多集的归档节目。此外，还有视频。有最喜爱节目的列表，帮助你找到想听的内容。再次说明，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
《美国生活》通过公共广播交换（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。